welcome back to CBS mornings and welcome
to a live look at Rome Italy about to
see the country's most right-wing
government since World War II Georgia
Maloney she is the leader of the
brothers of Italy party and she is in
line to become Prime Minister Chris
webslay is in Rome with reaction to
Sunday's big vote Chris good morning
this is historic on a couple fronts it
seems good morning to you
Good morning Tony yeah it's a stunning
victory for Georgia Maloney and her
brothers of Italy party suddenly because
they were just a fringe party up until a
few years ago and suddenly because of
Italy's disastrous history the last time
a hard-right party Rose to power
her name is Georgia Maloney and to the
brothers of Italy party she's here to
put traditional Italians First
Fundamental problem in Italy is becoming
the illegal immigration so many
immigrants if you want for example to
protect the traditional family a family
composed by Mom ajad and songs for
example how does she do that
not admitting the the marriages between
people from the same the same gender
Italy's conservative Superstar fiercely
opposes adoptions and surrogacy for
same-sex couples people like Alessandro
Valera and his husband who have a little
girl she's trying to
um
and delete us and send a message that we
are the cause of we are the reason why
Italy doesn't have enough children we
are the reason why
um we have demographic problems we are
the reason why the family is not holding
strong and we are scared the 45 year old
Firebrand insists she's no fascist just
a proud conservative and nationalist
comfortable nevertheless with some of
the Hallmarks of Italian fascism like
this motto
God Fatherland and family
exactly 100 years ago this fall fascist
dictator Benito Mussolini staged his
historic march on Rome eventually
marching the country into two decades of
dictatorship and alongside Hitler into
World War II neither IL Duce nor his
fascist party survived but several
descendants are active in politics today
like his granddaughter akele Mussolini a
member of the brothers of Italy so has
your last name been a hindrance or a
help
it's been both she says certainly when I
entered politics my last name was a
springboard
a springboard and a party with the very
symbol that's on Benito Mussolini's tomb
we a historical flame of the old party
but if there was no connection with
fascism oh no no but why wouldn't they
change their symbol then no no no no no
no no a red flag if there ever was one
says Edith Brooke a renowned poet and
Holocaust Survivor Georgia Maloney
says there's nothing to worry about
but are you worried yes very much
very very boring I think that she is
fascist
now to be clear Georgia Maloney rejects
that fascist label when it comes to
foreign policy she's been very
supportive of Ukraine but that's going
to be tested by the other parties in her
Coalition who have deep ties to Russian
President Vladimir Putin Tony
rejects the label but not all of the
slogans Chris Liz say for us on a
historic day in Rome Chris thank you
very much